recorded history mankind has boldly  pursued with every advance from the  great legends about foods named  knowledge gave birth to the greatest  tech destruction became inevitable one  money clip one pin one pack of demons  gentlemen that's not mine  what's not yours the pen I've never what  you saw was a place a miraculous secret  place no way we're the best and the  brightest people in the world came  together to actually change it where  nothing was impossible  stop it I saw this place I want you to  take me there  where'd you get this I know that you  were there  who are you kid  looking for something like for a very  long time  the future was running out  something happened over there  he thinks you can fix the future  there's a place  nothing's impossible you want to go